leather fellows caleche this is tuning it
peppers the doctor carey zo'n fj vd berg
right to cover
many important questions can live for
instance
how is this
this is holly bij
nou en showbizz how is it
this of course oro ali b and c show you
this piece of text how these two voor
toe and gigelli ben zo
wire discussion interesting well an
earlier deeper found out from been
reading
dat we in die het heft person je runs
in her leg die is a johans
specialized recognized particle argument
being that is quite interesting  and what
is even more interesting
is after we the person your ons bad the
disney runs
arm multi-modal what does that mean this
means that i understand the essence of
what makes ali b
regardless of whether it is a photo join
or anything jas
pc or  right way than a first question to
day is through networks or will him
multi-modal joran's
not necessarily that you my leg is an
in space jam of artificial euro
network that who can simulator compu  ters
but do they work like the brain
to view and faces
and says that this is in die the human
face so far so good
nou your free provider with the john ring of
someone face it won't recognize it to be
a face
wel so much for this multimedia
this one is surely not  to bring in the
job god knows how long that absolute ilio
rand here
this is not the turning your own network
architecture dat access
led grab the friend for this one scope
ops clip and this is my markably god
engineer leising concept let's see how
it can part  with the same problem
yes disneyland response to spiders and
spiderman
that is the easyport mount please hold on
two papers week is my chance
the hart bord
john links en connex' of spiders and
spiderman
the response to get to wonder for no  w
comes the final bas wedges
spider related drawings'
and
of course this doesn't mean that
this metro network brings some better into the
job but it is a tiny bit closer to air
thinking than previous architectures and
now comes  the best part
this insight open will the possibility for
free and mass index per month
experimentnummero en essence
sort appears to understand the essence
of the concept of the person
that is absolutely a sing along will a
wonder if i can turn this issues around
and how this  things but different concept
it becomes baby equivalent to seeing you
may of a spiders and spiderman
lesson purpose that the lady gaga
sds is the essence of lady gaga
we got this my smile refuses
and this says that the essence of jesus
christ is this and it us link  shed the
beads
of us
sofar flying colors
nou hoe we csa images of feelings' some
of you might find some of them the
stamping
he no the west majority of you people
have just fine loo  king at them but i
want it to let you know just in case so
what is the sns of
being sucked so he can do it so that
this is basically mee
when you ding this paper my eyes were
popping out just like this
sleep-in  is
yes that is a coffee person who for
coffee or right
crank de happinez and seriously no more
us already slim body this feels really well
experiment member to address a reality
win all that ops clip response to photos
and joys of so a none so lets try
some nasty at exin wolf in combining the
tool
we de wit these images this can
classified and hoodies ds is an apple
this is a laptop en markt and as long as
a too crazy shop here
however no less pierre and nasty
en vers ariel attack previously
sophisticen this  getting technical helps
the full on your network by adding
family in persepolis showing with level
also and how this work first 2% the
previous neural network with an image
of its boss and it we successful it and
slander isds is in that was
or  course it but now we should not an
image of a boss but a boss blow
suncare foil craft it never it is
miley perceptible
net hefty duo network then miss
classified as en ostrich
uilen stress that this is not any time
or again with the side of  noise with
exploits bias is in the your network
which it by no means trivio to craft
so well he hope you're expecting a
sophisticated adler would you let I have
just the wonderful clip in your network
is that we do
hear it
sea to gather
if then fine fino to this is
not an apple
ds is a pizza
so is this kind of
network file for these ones but it was
able to resist
the sophists chain jack in the case of the
coffee make and shape perhaps the pizza
labels
it to  small footprint in an image zo
lets try and even more sophisticated
version of the set up now you may think
that this is what you while but that is
completely wrong
lucas ds is a pizza to that extent
tsjoelala insight anywhere in this image
no n  o
so what how long do you intro stingray
this clip neural network is more
general than pbs technique however it
superpowers came
enterprise and that causes that it can
be exploited
easily with simple system label ex
that is a glass and in this experiment
number 2
understanding feelings  ' now this way
they wanna hack of an experiment
we will try to answer your questions
which i have described philips 2
machine a bit harder x-plane such a concept
met of us understand what billboard
news however lak you die is already
networks him you  once and they can use
those 2 x play as what they think about
the fun concept and interesting comment
is that feeling scoot kind of email is
a combination of other more elementary
uur ons bed aore who does differently
in this sound and little en apple's
let's go  daddy simple was the machine
think it means that someone is board
work it 6 dashboard is relaxed class
grumpy
this is an evil think about it but not
bad at all learn mac  hine and like the way
you think less right one more
hello x-plane two machine the
price will
be something like traveling celebration plus
jaqen meis
words bad madness let see here full
klaas
serious klaas hint of mental illness
and because also in debate  combinations dare
to my temples die really like it me
you're looking for text that embodies
evil wie get something like this
en again with it and your imagination
oh yes he is a networks wheelie though
via internet forum where who has black
belt experts specializing in  the waving
pap I so
share one of them please let me know in
the comments what you think
the peper also contains some more
information for instance this an
experiment
how it so junk effect this explores
making the neural network react to the
meaning of the text by  the room or the
text
he wants unethical death pika poverty
wheel i like you to read a paper smooches
a velomobile
in the video discription zo there we go
miro networks of by no mean  s beens in
the village
pff max computer programs however clip
has some seem like this
en wie was striking that this cost of
words time to be a la juicy here
you will part of this is a paper of told about
it was made by weight and buyers  and put
a link to hit in the description
nick types level also think it helps
you understand this paper better if you
work with learning a gray samsung
regular base is not sure to check out
woods en baisers der system is designed
to have you ordinateur experiment en  it
is so [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] shape of weeks or even
months of work for more projects and
this completely free
especially in the videos economics and open
source project this really is a good as
it gets
and it is hardly surprising that i am
now used by over  two hundred companies
and research institutions
nothing or to is the astrolabe and b dot
com slash papers
or just click the link in the video
description and you can get free
download today its thanks the waits and
basis for d  e long-standing support and
for heb inca's cousin both videos for
you for watching and for your generous
support and nothing you next time